Boston Province and the surrounding New
England areas we have a major alert for
you and we ain't talking about the snow
no we're talking about a low ticket
warning come out and see the live show
baby yeah guys it's a great way to
introduce your friends to the show grab
the crew grab the home he's grabbed the
bozos come out uh there's still some
tickets left for December 6th in
Providence at the second show out of the
The Late Show in Boston has a few
tickets left get them now let's party do
it gang this episode is brought to you
by our good friends over there at
established titles if you purchase as
little as one square foot of land you
yourself can call yourself a lord or a
lady that's all it takes baby it's not
only fun no but you helped preserve the
Scottish Woodlands what are you doing
huh yeah you know you don't like the
environment your dirt bag yeah what are
you some kind of non-hippy or something
whatever it is guys title packs give you
one at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
Edward Street and a Finnegan official
certificate Antichrist boom hit it right
there hey yo hey yo it makes you an
amazing last minute last minute gift and
baby we're in the gift giving season
right now so get on it well you know
you've been slacking you know you've
been on the uh your old Tick Tock you've
been following Elon Musk whatever it is
established titles is wearing a Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use a
code garbage you get an additional 10
off go to established titles.com garbage
to get your gifts now and help support
the channel baby support the people that
support the channel by going to
established titles.com garbage to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel do it welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out the group to be classy
after just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host Dave Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement I have some bad news
uh-oh tooty's missing oh God she's
missing what are we gonna do nothing for
a little while all right let's let the
heat blow over you know what I mean keep
cashing those checks Daddio my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
he is the CEO of are you garbage he is
the prince of Park Avenue but no matter
what time of the year it is the king of
the boardwalk baby give it up for Mr
Neptune
2006. KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure your rate of you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are out
baby they're cooking well over 100
over 18 million dollars what the [ __ ]
100 000 subscribers over there on
YouTube that explains Toody missing
she's got a treasure map she's looking
she walked in she's looking for cash she
walked in you counting money she had to
go I clipped her out real quick uh and
then obviously uh I would be remiss and
[ __ ] a jerk off a [ __ ] a piece of
[ __ ] a bozo if I didn't mention the
greatest website of all time guys take
out a pen and a pad a piece of paper
your browser your Internet Explorer your
Chrome whatever you're using
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out gang good time over there a
lot of content good time content that
anybody else out there
to that we I'll put everybody into the
test we got more content the Pepsi
challenge we call it my day I want my
Harrier jet too there you go why Harrier
jet that was a big thing there's a
there's a documentary now Pepsi was
giving away a Harrier jump jet no well
they there was a a commercial where you
could get like glasses a t-shirt a
leather jacket and then at the end it
was like Harry or jet seven million
points and this guy did the little snoop
and snagging and yeah say for like it
didn't say like joking obviously and uh
he wanted it yeah oh yeah yeah no he
can't they say yeah the whole thing
check it out on Netflix after you're
done did they give it to him I don't I
don't want to ruin it for the people out
there just be handing out Jets and so I
want a Huey helicopter Iroquois yeah
with the door gunner who's gonna pay
that guy some old school guy uh those
are like 35 mil oh [ __ ] now we know
where Toady is a lot of wild cherry peps
out there how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer X Jordan Air the
magic man makes us all look good he's
got a big old dick on him gang Give It
Up T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen family
program what's up guys what's up Mom yo
when they were doing those challenges
they would have the codes underneath the
the Caps did you ever before purchasing
the drink tilted sideways to try and see
if it was a winner see if he could catch
a hanger Dan that's pretty smart they
don't really do that [ __ ] anymore did
they well they started putting in the
play before he didn't have to peel and
you could kind of see the code and then
you had to start peeling off that that
layer to love that blue pea it makes my
blood run better get it
um we don't do cool [ __ ] like that
anymore as a society do we what we don't
do like cool giveaways like that you are
the oldest man in the world we don't we
don't do we don't do cool stuff we don't
do cool stories a billion dollars what
are you talking about whatever who the
[ __ ] wants a leather jacket from Pepsi I
just want one of those octopuses that
rolls down the wall they don't do good
things in cereal anymore the only thing
that is halfway decent are the kinder
eggs and that's not even American
company that's Europeans German they're
all right you get like a little race car
a little dinosaur a little something you
open up a Cracker Jack or a fiddle fatal
or something like that it's all crap
it's nothing good we should do cool
stuff like that anymore that's what this
country needs to bring everybody
together is a big giveaway the lottery
dude it's billions that's not the snow
little kids can't do that yeah they can
no they can't you aren't playing
scratchers as a kid tell me right now
we'll talk off exactly what are you
talking about you split it you got to
split it with your creepy if you get it
you split that with me
I see what you're saying you see what
I'm saying a little bit but maybe they
are we just don't know we don't have
kids you're like you're going like kids
zoomed in I know what's going on tuned
in I got nieces and nephews and little
cousins I know what's going on no you
don't yeah are you telling me who who
now who knows who are those kids that
were kicking me in the [ __ ] I'm sad I
know I'm saying you have them you're not
that tuned in I know what's going on out
there okay I know what's going on sure
all right we're not doing cool giveaways
I watch the commercials there's no Pepsi
this there's no Mountain Dew yeah
because they got jammed up and had to
give away a [ __ ] Harrier jet the
liability on this alone what are you
talking about it's just goddamn
litigious Society we're living in some
guy in Michigan with it Abrams you throw
a [ __ ] decoder ring in a Cracker Jack
box next you know kids are choking on it
and [ __ ] I know it sucks yeah that the
high dives everything somebody always
high dive somebody always ruins it they
had to get rid of all the hide that some
kid cracked his head open and jumping
off the side playing tomfoolery and
doing grab assets you get up there
you're scared to death you jump off and
then you swim over to the sound like a
gentleman would you ever jump off one of
those Ledges like those big diving
ledges I know nothing would happen to
you hey still scare the [ __ ] maybe
that's a patreon goal dude me and the
big guy talking cliff jumping no no I
can't jump I almost lost my leg from the
knee down and that was only like eight
feet
Tippy is not I learned early I'm not an
Outdoorsman that was in the bathtub
um no me and you rock olympic diving
pools they have diving boards then they
have those Ledges oh yeah yeah the one
that Bam Margera all laid off of yeah
yeah yeah yeah that ain't happening is
that how you know everything that's your
reference to everything right It's my
contextualized life wait Johnny
Knoxville jumped off the roof with a
pentagon oh I know that totally ever
been to Cracker Barrel yeah Ryan Dunn
got thrown out of one in 2002. rest in
peace all right
don't be Sully in the name of this shout
out to him oh this episode through it
I was gonna come get you shout out to
Mystic Dunn
um I wanted to ask you what do you got
big Feller I noticed something I was at
a relative house this weekend I noticed
something something pretty trashy uh
either you guys have any family members
or in your house or your house growing
up was the light to the bathroom on the
outside of the door yikes yeah that's
when you're really now whoa that's when
you know on the outside on the outside
that oh that's something you're going to
the bad school you're going to the Bay I
can't find the lights on the outside of
the door oh yeah no you can't you gotta
no what that'd be like residential
that'd be like giving your brother the
nuclear codes oh yeah oh it makes her a
real good Escape you're [ __ ] all
over the floor and stuff [ __ ] out of
here turn it back on dude yeah
kind of like yeah in the same vein
um we used to uh what about this that
thing I got one of those in my closet in
my apartment now you do it's kind of fun
it's a good time yeah every time I pull
one of them I'm just waiting for a witch
waiting for a [ __ ] iron to come down
and hit me in the head
a bunch of bowling balls no that's more
scary to me that you hear that that was
always down in the basement that's the
first thing that always that's the first
time to know you're in a haunted house
when that thing doesn't go right away
if that thing gives you trouble on the
first bull get out it's only gonna get
worse dude I'm bolting up the steps I
still run up I gotta say grown man
pretty sure there's no boogie man sure I
run up the steps of the basement at my
mother's house of course man I throw
this [ __ ] third guy I'm out
my brother's seller is frightening a
seller's scarier than a basement get it
crawl space is where the [ __ ]
heebie-jeebies live I gotta crawl space
now yeah we have one at my mom's I
probably used to go in there and hide
yikes [ __ ] go face to face with El
Diablo
that guy like to look death in the eyes
and keep pushing holy [ __ ] man I
wouldn't go in there without any nickel
on me ever never said he wasn't
distracted to the gills never if I had
to go in there I would just scream and
cry until they'd fine I'll go in and get
it we yeah make Patty go in and get it
so we have our you've been in my better
hair than me
she's lived a life
I'm a Young Man a young boy I got my
whole life in front of me
we had the the basement right you've
been in my basement it's a short it's
the tours on patreon we have the
basement and then there's like a second
smaller back room no but then off that
is the utility room holy [ __ ] and then
in the utility they're small in the
utility room there's the crawl space and
each room gets colder and colder as yeah
so demons you can feel the spirits
that's no good it goes the dog won't go
in there just stands there barking
it goes finish basement
then it goes the room behind the
finished basement that for some reason
storage we're doing storage then you got
the crawl space down there that's where
you store the Jersey Devil
keeps his luggage in there
hey guys I'm going abroad I gotta stop
by and pick up my roller bags there's
beers in there
um and then you go unfinished basement
would be scarier with the you know you
hit the [ __ ]
um the water heater and stuff like that
there's all kinds of things around where
you swear you can see somebody just like
peeking out from behind something yeah
first of all one thing we never did that
I never allowed in my house there was
never any covering of the furniture like
if we if like we had a basement in our
house in Wilkes-Barre and we had some
old furniture down there and I remember
for for a minute when we moved in my mom
put sheets around them I'm like yeah Lou
you Bruce Wayne you're not covering get
rid of that that's not happening no we
never did we just ruined [ __ ] we you
know and then the scariest is a seller
it's just a straight dirt floor seller
which we had with my grandparents had
one in Wilkes-Barre and it smelled like
death yeah it's all like mold not like
the 1800s there was the farmhouse in my
neighborhood like we said you know that
my neighborhoods developed on an Old
Farm and they keep a lot of places kept
The Farmhouse yeah that's scary enough
and this kid Ryan lived there he was
possessed for sure dude that kid was
cuckoo bananas that whole family was
rough and right you want a skateboard
now I'm gonna go and spin my head around
a couple of times
I'm gonna speak in tongues I'll be right
back
hey you sleep on the ceiling huh it's
scary man and we would have to go play
in like the like the shed and the cell
and [ __ ] the shed the shed is where they
kept all the toys it was so cold even in
the dead of Summer dude it was so cold I
remember like reaching down for like a
basketball or something [ __ ]
something bit me
dude who keeps our toys in the shed oh
like Wiffle ball stuff yeah not yet not
like yeah yeah yeah like sport like
outdoor stuff a bike of the balls a
wiffle ball I'm good I'll see you in
school I'm out of there I didn't like
that [ __ ] at all but the light on the
outside is
usually the bathroom
It's usually the bathroom yeah but why
is that that doesn't make sense I don't
know so you don't have to go in to turn
it off is that the only is is the only
uh when I was in there fumbling around
in the dark for about two minutes trying
to take a tanky and I finally I yelled
is it a newer house or an older house
Beyond old yeah okay yeah like big bang
old okay yeah it's crazy it's just some
Carbon on the wall all right that kind
of makes sense the light switch is a
giant lever yeah like iron stuff
I gotta be Edison to take a leap
that makes a little bit I just don't
want to piss on the floor I don't like
Frank
[Laughter]
but now after a couple after like a
minute in there I was like oh wait a
minute and I peeked out and then I just
flipped it on and it came on I was like
yeah that's I didn't like it uh-uh no
dice those weird window panes
yeah older houses kind of irk me
beautiful
I always said I would do if I was
goodbye I would want to do new
construction or something that like I
don't want something so old something 20
years so I you know something before I
was alive creeps me out it's like oh
this is built in 92 I go I got it I
remember the 90s nothing nothing you
know there was no crazy headlines or
whatever Kurt Cameron's gonna pop out
yeah who's gonna get me there yeah okay
one of the Ninja Turtles let's go uh but
yeah something built in the 18 that's
[ __ ] I live in a pre-war building
right now that's different though
there's no ghost in New York I don't
know yeah there are where are they what
are you talking about they're hanging no
somebody definitely died in my apartment
doesn't mean there's ghosts there
they're about to die in your apartment
I'm definitely haunting you kidding me
yeah something dude what's for dinner
all right but let's get into it gang we
got a family episode Family episode so
as you know when you join the old
patreon we will answer your garbage
question that's one of the perks to
joining the old page one of what a Manny
perks you can get that hard feelings you
get that ayg bonus you got a lot of Vlog
bonus behind the scenes content coming
up too plus we're thinking about buying
a timeshare everybody to get in on it
get three hours every year and we should
do one we should all pull our money
everybody should pull their money and
buy like a mountain house and everybody
gets like
there's not enough time at night I guess
everybody gets three hours
all right let's get into it this one's
from Michael has anyone in your family
ever been asked to put their Sig out by
a police officer
sir can you put that cigarette down
please
so I'm gonna have to ask you to put down
that marble light uh I have yeah
yeah when I was uh uh it was I was 18. I
remember I was uh we got caught underage
drinking down the shore house cops came
in sure
and he was like where's your ID and I
was smoking inside back in the day
pre-2005 you could smoke anywhere then
just crack a window and it was fine who
are you Clint Eastwood yes the cops come
in you're putting the cigarette out when
they eat right it was pretty still
smoking I was trying to I was trying to
act like I was over 21.
officer I have the confidence to smoke
in front of you you're holding the baby
uh but I was looking for my wallet in my
room and I had to sink in my mouth I was
I was drunk all right couldn't find my
wall because he asked for ID so I'm
digging through my like bag and I
remember the smoke kept burning my eye
because I I needed both I had to sit in
my mouth so you know you do not win yeah
I hate that ah and I was bending down so
it was coming right up in my eye and
he's like why don't you put that
cigarette out the house
I'll get right back to business you
light up another one doing yeah I take
that copper yeah this guy yeah I was
driving a young guy no I was a young
drunk you always put the Sig out when
the heat rolls in let's go oh yeah I
didn't know I mean I panicked I wasn't
thinking straight I heard Patty got
pulled over one time and she was
you're allowed to smoke when you're
pulled over I mean what's the deal here
yeah he didn't appreciate it yeah I
don't think it's not like an honorable
uh
so you might put that cigarette out
if the cherries and berries ever lit up
behind you at high school it was always
light sigs to cover up the weeds that
was always a big thing too if you're
underage drinking or smoking weed or got
weed in the car hit the Bernie's heavy I
used to keep a pack of ports right in
the glove box just to get that deep rich
menthol smell going came a box of
Macadoodles in the club officer
I'm having a boy
what do you say you join me in a nice
hey it's a Cuban don't tell anybody
don't write me up will you
oh that's a home run home run yeah yeah
love that sigs by the I don't have a
whole lot of experience getting pulled
over
two three times maybe you want to know
one of my greatest achievements was
um was I was driving home I was at home
I was driving I had I was smoking a
heater a stinger Stinger Bernie
um
cop behind me
I flick it out the window sure
my job lights me up we're gonna light
them up I'm a proud supporter at a
police department pulled me over so I
pull up my PBA card professional bowlers
[Laughter]
um no he pulls me over and I I saw that
he was behind me so I just I field
scripted you know what that means yeah
you put the cherry out yeah and then you
take the keep the filter because that's
the part that contaminates the planet
yeah I put that my little my little
thing
pull over pulls me over he comes I saw
you flick that cigarette out and I go I
go what do you mean I have it right here
he goes
oh
walk back to his car followed me for
about half an hour
but they were posted up out front of the
house for us make a move fat ass which I
appreciate the chase the hell up in a
cat and mouse keep everybody keep
everybody honest I like it I like it I
want to show up with the boys I uh I got
pulled over one time at the Lincoln
Tunnel I was coming up to do a bringer
show which for The Listener bringer
shows were like uh the height of the
entertainment industry oh man it's
you're doing bringer shows are tough as
a new comedian the club goes or like a
producer goes hey you can be on my show
but you got to bring six people some dad
six is a little it's like 15. can you
bring 12 people and that's the way that
they packed to pack the club out it's a
bit of a money making scheme for
everybody involved but the comedian sure
um but it is what it is I was happy to
do the time
um put me and my pal uh John Nunn were
coming up and he flicked this thing out
at the we were going through the tunnel
and he [ __ ] lit us up where there's
no shoulder a guy behind New Jersey
state trooper lit us up chasing it
through the tunnel no he chased me I
stopped but now I'm just blocking a lane
of the tunnel at like [ __ ] six
o'clock yeah right I swear to God does
he get out yeah he got out came up
because you know why I pulled you over
what are you doing from here let me see
your license blah blah blah and we were
like oh we're going to a comedy show
he's like [ __ ] Rush Hour buddy what
do you think yeah hitting casing
Pennsylvania what are you doing I'm like
oh we're up here for a comedy show goes
ah who you seeing and right there I kind
of knew I had him ago we're actually
comedians he goes ah no [ __ ] how long
you've been on the circuit I'm like all
right here we go about 10 minutes
what are you doing in an hour I could
use two more guys
do you have any dinner plans
probably you and the misses come over
tonight did he write you up no he just
goes let me make sure none of you guys
have warrants on you and I'm sitting
next to John London if you don't know
him he looks like a [ __ ] bouncer for
the Hell's Angels
the whole nine ago are you gonna come
out of this he goes I don't know man
let's see if that stuff got cleared up
I'm like all right
all right man he came back he's like
enjoy the show or whatever okay let's
talk about seven straws oh baby this one
is near and dear to the big man man's
heartbeat I'm not even selling it I'm
just telling you the truth you've all
been hitting me up Foley where do you
get those cool shirts I responded I sent
you the link this is it seven strong
yeah I've had Comics other bigger
gentlemen hit me up and say where's big
man getting on his fly gear they go up
to 4X they are flexible they are
comfortable they look good uh they don't
wrinkle really it's unbelievable trust
me and you can wrinkle a shirt throw it
in your bag you fluff it out it's ready
to go let me tell you something I love
these shirts I love these shirts they're
comfortable they're cool they make me
look sharp they make me feel good these
shirts feel like me that's all I'm gonna
say you're gonna be buried in one I'm
sure probably not that far away uh these
shirts are for the folks who want to
have fun every day baby good cool photos
court date wedding whatever you got
trying to get your kids back this is
what they do shout out to seven strong
the boys they all come out to the shows
in California we [ __ ] love you guys
right now seven strong is getting ready
to bring the for their Black Friday sale
running the Black Friday through Cyber
Monday uh with up to 34 percent off most
items this is the best time to give the
Wardrobe a refresh and as a special deal
just for garbage listeners visit
seven-strong.com that's the number seven
Dash strong.com and use our code
ayg5 to get an additional five dollars
off one code per customer some
restrictions apply sales prices will be
applied in the cart seven strong
everyday wear for everybody do it
they're the best let's talk about freeze
piping they call me Mr Freeze over there
let's talk about pulling two ripping
bangers that was my biggest complaint
back in the day man your throat would
get hot it would burn your throat all
that stuff freeze pipe you throw it in
the freezer cools everything down gives
you a nice thick Cloud it's really a
good time man and it's a sharp looking
piece of equipment
comes in a cool box I feel official with
that thing yeah no more throat bar no
more tense coughing tax no more chugging
water after every rip baby the secret is
the freezable glycerin chamber that come
on every piece pop one of these Chambers
in the freezer for about an hour and
you're ready to start cooking smoke is
instantly cold as it passes through the
icy chamber change how you smoke forever
baby pipes bobblers bongs dabra dab rigs
and more if you can smoke it freeze pipe
makes it so head over to
thefreezepike.com and enjoy your new
favorite piece what do we do every day
great prices use code garbage for 10 off
your next order that's the thiefreeze
pipe.com code garbage Safe 10 shop today
your throat and lungs will thank you do
it see you on Pluto shout out to none uh
I love it but home run I have a question
this one in the same world this is from
Jake 10 dirt bag shout out is it garbage
for me to wear a golf glove while I'm
ripping darts in the car so my wife
doesn't smell it on my hands when I get
home
I respect that but it's other places too
but the hands are the worst yeah that's
tough even you know a hand wash don't
get that off
you gotta wash sanitize and then like
eat Doritos or something when somebody
rolls in from having a having a smoke
outside in the cold well I remember your
uncle would do that when he rolled you
you do it you come in here smelling like
a [ __ ] ashtray sometimes I don't
smoke cigs what this whole show is based
on the premise of me and you [ __ ]
ripping Bernies we sell shirts that say
burn ah man
glad that my primary care physician
today about that so you're still not
smoking yeah doing good feel great
eating two packs a day though uh
uh yeah they know he knows they know I
was smoking in the office so you're
gonna have to put that out are you still
smoking
you ever have a doctor tell you to put
this thing out
um I remember that was the big Dirtbag
thing like in college and stuff if the
doctor found out you smoked your
insurance would get all [ __ ] up
so you always said no and I caved the
one time and I was like yeah you know I
have one now he's like so you are a
smoker I think no no no I swear to God
[ __ ] marked me I marked it down in my
file
yeah I was where he's gonna call my mom
and tell her I was back on the heaters
it's fat little best
um I had a quick one for you fellas
what's up Toby you lead you alluded to
it on the Natasha Leggero episode
but I had the thought beforehand which
Kismet you brought it up if you have a
lot of cash no wallet are you going
large bills on the outside or small
bills on the outside I mean the wise guy
um etiquette would be
as Lefty from Mulberry Street said
[ __ ] on the outside you have a [ __ ]
on the outside keep the hundred on the
outside this is my thing but I'm also
but these animals in this city don't
jump out the window at you to get it if
they if you're if you're flexing a five
yeah but you still want to keep up
appearances true right so it's a it's a
fine line you gotta dance on the street
you invert it
no this is what I do
go ahead uh if I'm leaving the house
right leaving the house I got my money
from the day before whatever I dropped
the ones off
I don't take the one I don't leave the
house with ones look at my little I have
like a little savings account a little
jar we put all the ones in if you need
like milk money whatever I'll run any
others you know there's 20 30 bucks
there whatever don't Lenny who are you
living with he's stupid he's your
opinion she's moving with a little
rascals
you remember from do you remember Red
Man's crib MTV Cribs yeah we had the
shoe box over his fridge his dollar box
I've always wanted a dollar box and I've
never had enough dollars to maintain a
dollar box but now I have a dollar box
okay so if you ever just need one
whatever you know tips or whatever I
like having ones on me
nah two whatever so I only leave the
house with twenties really yeah two two
three twenties that's it that's what I'm
that's what I'm rocking with two three
twenties okay spot pay you bury if you
get a hundo from you know condo spot pay
nice you bury that in the middle out of
20s real so again unless people think
like oh he's at least got 20 bucks
what's on the inside who knows who knows
I always go I was always told to go
small bills on the outside so you don't
get jumped or whatever yeah but like I
said you want to [ __ ] you know you
want to look cool you want to look cool
it can't be flashing ones like a Bose
the Trashy answer I think is one's on
the outside and then all classes you got
you got your heavy bike rolling outside
because then you're going places where
it doesn't matter yeah but it's like if
you have 100 and then 220s it's like so
aware that you're trying to show off
that hundred you need like four grand to
be like yeah I keep that they're all
hundreds it doesn't matter
but if you have if you have one oh a
hundred dollar bill surrounding like
three ratty ones oh yeah that's a bad
look straight straight to fives
have you ever seen the that's a tough
one the picture of of Puff Daddy
Courtside holding a wad of hundreds and
120 and he's looking at the 20 like how
the [ __ ] this is something like what is
this
who gave me this it's not even worth my
time to count it I heard a clip from I
think it was Brad Williams uh this
weekend he he did I guess he was
traveling somewhere I believe it was
Brad Williams he did he was traveling
somewhere and he had I guess they were
told get a shitty cell phone and a fake
wallet in case you get robbed that's
what you hand over that's a that's a
move I wouldn't mind having that was
back in the day that was the 80s Colin
Quinn says it uh in his show uh the New
York uh the New York show is you'd have
your mugger money they'd say hey have
your mugger money on you that's that's
20 bucks rolled up and they go hey give
me your money and you go here's here's
my mugger money that's not bad he goes
you got to a point where they're like
just give me your 20 that you already
like I won't take everything just give
me the 20. that's a gentleman's thing
that's hey getting robbed one thing I
don't want to have to [ __ ] go to the
DMV and deal with all that [ __ ] yeah
because my wallet it's like to me
had that thing forever it might not be
this episode
we might be loyal to another brand ooh
nice
um all right this one's from banister
Lannister don't think that's his first
name
uh ever got an Airborne in a car
dude you're [ __ ] up if all four
wheels come off the ground once and I
was so [ __ ] mad at my friend for uh
letting us drive to school with this kid
who the kid buddies is it a dune buggy
on the way to school
they get airborne on the way to school
seven o'clock in the morning [ __ ]
hitting the gas so uh me and my boy me
and my boy live in the same neighborhood
this kid lived in the same neighborhood
and him and I I think at the time were
taking turns driving you drive I'll
drive you drive
so he's like he's like he's like Josh is
going to drive us never like the new guy
in the mix a friend of a friend I hate
he did two moves and I was an old man
then I didn't like that [ __ ] I didn't
like jumping off the roof into the pool
or [ __ ] going to the Quarry kids get
off my roof nah I don't like anything I
didn't like doing dangerous [ __ ] or I
was gonna end up as the [ __ ] you see
what happens yeah I mean Patty and Terry
instilled that in me like when they
would put like the car out in front of
the high school near prom that [ __ ]
petrified me like going to prom I didn't
I didn't I drove I didn't drink anything
I wore three condoms I only did anal
didn't even get one I knocked his bra up
put them on after the shower
I didn't like wearing them there I
didn't like that [ __ ] okay and he picks
us up and he's got a I think he had a
zephyr you know what a zephyr is it was
an old piece of [ __ ] car
and over on this one street Cathcart
Road there was like this little hump I
know hey there's a humping every town
and man out of nowhere he's like what
just he's like watch this and [ __ ]
and dude I had a [ __ ] wrestling meet
that night I was like dude what are you
doing man [ __ ] I freaked out and then
as we got closer to school there was
this other uh there was a house that had
a horseshoe driveway that went from one
road to the other he pulls in there real
fast and goes to their horse show that
was kind of fun but the jumping didn't
like that [ __ ] that [ __ ] the kids do now
is crazy they're all standing in a
circle spinning the cars and they all
want to get hit by the car
you break a hip I don't trust that like
the what is that what do they do Toby
might know how I don't know how they do
that I'm not a car guy
how do they do that thing where like
how do they do donuts they hold in the
break or what's going on with the front
of the car staying where they're
spinning there's got to be something
cooking there I don't know but it's
irresponsible well as you go home and
get your homework done yeah you have a
license as an unlicensed Street racer
myself
back in the day our friends used to go
down to the races North Carolina drift
our friends just go down to the couple
of kids growing up had like real shitty
Mustangs appearance yeah yo for sure
single family home like Dad was you know
somewhere and would send checks and then
you know it was a Loveless household
date bounce a lot of pit bulls floating
around too sure
um kick it smokes eggs out front of the
house at like 14 15 years cool and
orange she don't care yeah
like one of those kids were like do you
have parents like I've never seen them
they've never showed up to pick you up
at the basketball games or anything yeah
um I bet it's always hanging out under a
street light couple houses where there's
holes punched in the wall in the living
room wow yeah you save that [ __ ] for the
bedroom but kids would go down to the
races uh which ones down in South Philly
like by the airport like on like oh like
like illegals right yeah like like the
dragon we're not talking about the
Trotters here
not talking about Belmont dude talking
about [ __ ] like no mint juleps and
weird hats no like South Philly street
races on like Wednesday nights no and
I'm like because Fast and Furious was
banging by [ __ ] everybody wanted a
souped up Civic sure uh myself included
it's always the cars like half shitty
half and I never got it but I remember
friends of mine of ours would be like
yeah we're going down to the races
tonight I'd like fake a tummy ache come
back buddy I can't make it about that
life no dude no [ __ ] way nobody's
talking to Cheesesteak or something you
know what I mean yeah family matters I
wish we could help out yeah yeah it's
never happened but we did have the hump
where you would like my dad would like
speed over it like let's say kids like
just like scare us or whatever real cool
guy scaring the [ __ ] I've been in the
back of the pickup when the people have
done a little bit version of that too oh
yeah we were back we were a big back of
the pickup kids older kids it's like my
brother's friends are driving us
somewhere they had a pickup they'd get
catch us on something but a little bit
to shake us up this was I'm [ __ ] I
got half a Pop-Tart in me it's [ __ ]
eight o'clock in the morning I'm on my
way to school my hair's still wet from
the shower and this guy's playing
[ __ ] evil can evil talking just to
try to fit in you're killing me here
uh-huh uh home run of a question though
home run all right this one's from uh B
Patron I guess 10 shareholder uh
did you or anyone in your family ever
own a hookah
which is the trashiest of the tobacco
smoking that if you're pulling tubes out
of it dude yeah but then still I mean
who's smoking just smoke a bong or a
[ __ ] right here I don't know
somebody's dad had one and this is
before I knew that you were supposed to
smoke uh tobacco no they don't smoke
tobacco out of a hookah yeah they do
it's like incense or myrrh or something
like a tobacco I don't think so it's
like ash or something uh it's called
shisha I believe
okay uh and it's a it's like a wet
tobacco yeah it's tobacco it's like
flavored tobacco they put coals on there
so it like continues to burn maybe
that's roasting some beef stickers
I'm sure it's cool rip tubes
um but yeah like we had we had one that
had like four different tubes and you
put weed in it we'd all smoke yeah
smoking yes yeah that's a little I mean
I think it's trashier to have one for
just tobacco use than anything
I mean some cultures that cultures they
do yeah yeah of course I mean yeah
I live in the Heights which is a lot of
uh predominantly Dominican and they it's
like huge the hookahs are hookah lounges
really yeah I mean most of New York uh
has most of the cult like you can't go
like four blocks outside
what Middle Eastern Casablanca it's ever
it's everywhere it's like there's a lot
of cultures really leaned into it I
think of like some fat cat smoking it
hello Rick yeah no it's uh I mean out on
the streets everything it's like posting
up I mean all like the are you going to
most [ __ ] uh uh bodegas they sell
hookah [ __ ] really yeah yeah at least
the tubes the [ __ ] whatever yeah I'm
sure your fancy sleepily School you
probably smoked that [ __ ] nah we had it
in my Dirtbag Flop House in Chicago
though there you go a hookah oh yeah
were you smoking hookah were you smoking
doobies out of it uh mostly it would
just be shisha or whatever and then
occasionally someone throw some nugs in
there do a little you know do a little
Steinway split a little spliff type deal
dogs is all right
KIPP it's kamakoto time baby
it's time to slice through that
Thanksgiving turkey like a hot knife
through butter baby
kamikota builds over 800 years of
Japanese experience in creating steel to
make knives that have been meticulously
handcrafted using techniques that date
back to Japan's Edo periods one of my
favorite periods that Ito period of
course nothing wrong with it gang
absolutely fantastic knives they're
single bevel Edge can achieve and
unbelievable sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives don't be a bozo
what are you doing you can cut through a
rib eye like butter uh-huh I'm telling
you buddy they were nice enough to send
me a package of them I comes in a nice
wooden thing
flip it open nice soft in there got him
I mean me my wife were sword fighting in
a goddamn kitchen uh choose by Michelin
star chefs worldwide every knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee and each knife comes
in a gorgeous heavy duty Ashwood box
like I just said there you go so give
gifting a set or two is a no-brainer in
this time of year but it knows that
comicoto has several has several special
offers going on right now and is
offering our viewers an extra fifty
dollars off any purchase with the code
garbage just go to comicoto.com garbage
that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash garbage use
the promo code garbage for fifty dollars
off the best Japanese steel knives on
the planet do it okay if it's time for
movement baby oh baby it's time for
movement and a shaking gang a lot of
people do things one way why don't you
be a trendsetter and do things the other
way switch it up that's what two College
dropouts did in an apartment back in the
day when they created the greatest watch
company of all time clean designs top
quality product yeah and here's turkey
what's that what do you think gobble
gobble fraction at a price
we don't love a fraction of the price
fraction of the price now you're
speaking my language dad there you go
guys the good Folks at movement we've
been talking about it for years now they
they were nice enough to send uh send me
a nice watch baby I might I love it I
this is how much of a bozo I am they
sent me a watch I went out I gotta get
an expensive watch I wanna bought
expensive watch I like movements watch
better it looks cooler it looks better
my wife likes it better I try to throw a
move on here she's jumping down whatever
watches are just the beginning of
movements line they have eyewear jewelry
uh designed to set you up new blockers
too oh but it's the best so be a good
gift Giver with movement during their
seasonal sale get a special discount
just in time for the holidays join
movement today at mvmt.com that's
mvmt.com do it Camp established titles
baby let's run it back one more time hey
ladies hey Lords big fans of established
titles over here on the show see you got
to get a 10 let the heat blow over get
some land over there in Scotland yeah
hide out for a little bit I know this is
the only way I'm I'm a goddamn landowner
is by established titles there you go
ain't nobody else giving me a square
foot of land nowhere else hey my
grandfather said buy a real estate they
ain't making any more of it there you
guys the smartest thing I ever heard you
say baby guys with every order of titles
with every order established titles
plants a tree and works with global
Charities how about that to support
Global Reef reforestation efforts title
packs give you uh at least one square
foot of dedicated land on private estate
in edelston Scotland an official
certificate with a crass boom we got one
right here we got T-Bones guy when I got
one big man got one get that put on your
license the first 200 people purchased a
title pack using our link will
effectively be next to our plots with a
few minutes of walking we can be
neighbors we can build our own garbage
Kingdom baby makes a great last minute
gift and uh stay off my lawn established
titles is running a Black Friday sale
plus if you use the code garbage you get
an additional 10 percent off go to
establishtrails.com garbage get your
gifts now and help support the channel
tell it who's talking today about
blowing shotguns was that you yeah
blowing shot yeah you were making you're
making fun of my mom told me saying that
you blowing shotguns I I've been meaning
to ask you guys for like a month hit me
what do you could have spent every day
together for the past three months dude
no I know I just keep slipping my mind
what do you call it when you hold in
smoke so long that when you exhale
nothing comes out oh
um goat not ghost ghost in it maybe
ghosting that's a popular one how do you
call it a drug addiction I believe
uh you'd have a name for that bully
um I don't think so zeroing not so
popular maybe I don't know we did used
to have I remember smoking a blunt and
my short-lived uh weed career I would
Panic like a [ __ ]
smoking a blunt on the side of this
kid's house uh who was like you know
still Rough Around the Edges this kid
this is one of those where you're like
what are your or do you have parents
those type kids smoking a blunt and they
can't have the idea I think they called
it the Chicago you Chicago it where you
take we were also 12 so like somebody
could have just made this up completely
where you take a hit and then it goes
around and you're not allowed to Exhale
until it gets back to you that's a good
time man my world inverted
I might as well been an Inception dude
my world turned upside down because you
exhale and then hit it again so you're
like that's the only thing you're
getting is [ __ ] blunt smoke as a 12
year old where were you on that one mom
when a super hot chick would would
shotgun that was pretty cool with you
yeah I never had that oh really shout
out to my boy Pat I had him a couple of
times and then he went to skinny yeah
laughs
oh man
um all right here this is just this is
Murph the God ever seen your own [ __ ]
yeah absolutely how
mirrors
I went down there to NASA I did a full
spread with Amy leebowitz what do you
think [ __ ] I was probably shaving my
bucket my Concho over here pulled his
butt apart it's like Indiana Jones where
he has the 19 mirrors
some poor Egyptian kid holding it up
Hashim
it's like in The Fifth Element he's
yelling at him
hold the light
I think I might have seen a moment ghost
started coming out everywhere
that thing's haunted for sure what's the
last time you touched your own butthole
like
finger touched your butthole
this morning in the shower right yeah
probably all right cool yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we also grow with a pathological liar
because that's crazy yeah I've looked
I've seen everything looked at
everything fiddled with everything the
whole nine yards you got to know your
own body sure I don't I think I've taken
disgusting his mind is I think I've
taken a glance back in like high school
or college it was like all right that's
enough for me dog you know what I mean
hey don't yeah I know it's there we
don't [ __ ] talk and we keep it moving
you know we're gonna step down at
Christmas how you doing good to see it
you're doing good yeah I'm doing good
all right talk to you later he's
probably a little beat up nowadays
though but you never have a hemorrhoid
that'll scare God into you bro
for sure I have the most of the time
[Laughter]
I went away and look at it hey come on
in will you
that's the first time I looked yeah it's
a little messy down there a little spare
tire back there I looked he was looking
right back at me
what are you doing for Christmas you got
a light you mind putting that sick up
hey hemorrhoid you might put that stick
out for a minute
I got a lot of discoloration around them
the outer the outer rim look like a burn
victim
it's bad yeah that's what I I don't want
to know like an oak tree you can count
how many years it's been around
yeah bad news uh-huh I wish I get it all
bleached back then it all cleaned up I
mean you can all right focus on bigger
issues at hand the bleaching your
butthole at the moment penis enlargement
I'm with you get in there all right this
one's from Eric uh is it garbage if your
whole family slept on Waterbeds my
parents still have one 35 years strong
[Laughter]
we had one in the house my stepdad had
one I guess in his uh single days and
then when he moved into my mom's we
brought it over my brother used it for a
long time which I've said I don't know
how and I haven't been on one since you
know I was eight or whatever
how do you
how do you have intercourse on one yeah
I feel like you'd uh
I feel it's very ins my memory of it
would be very unstable you slap the wave
at your feet and then you're right I was
the body body body surfing champ of
Wildwood it's normal
I only probably did it once or twice
because I had it when I was like 16 or
17. you know what I mean like a cat
walking on the top of a pool cover I'm
trying to figure it out what are you
getting into there what you get your
hands up everybody
you sit back and enjoy you let her do
the work
and do the work
my cousins had two is it good for your
back can you get can you get eyes on
that like is it good for did it work
they went back and forth and said that
like the water wasn't good if the heater
broke in the middle of the night you
could it could kill you because you
would like go on a hypothermia I don't
know I thought it was pretty chill
yeah pretty snug had him for a lawyer
there's a one in my house for a long
time all right water beds are good for
the back and can help them up with
muscle tension pressure points pressure
sores and back pain next paragraph a
waterbed can cause back pain yeah it's
all [ __ ] I'm out do they still make
them though I'm sure think so huh yeah
yeah probably I mean you know probably
not a whole bunch we uh when mine got
popped because I threw it pretty much
just a [ __ ] air mattress so you pull
water in it yeah uh I threw a temper
tantrum one night it's not a kick in my
bed and I popped it didn't realize it
and then like a couple hours later my
brother came in and jumped on it and
he's like [ __ ] almost yeah how to
call Allstate so we had a [ __ ] use
the hose to drain it
but I slept in that bed for about a year
with a with a a full-size mattress in
there whoa inside the water bed that's a
tough look tray that's what we call
white tree but it was actually kind of
cool it was cozy
uh does it just fit and I have like I
have like a little space between that
and the headboard put your snacks put my
snacks put like my GI Joes a couple
comic books a couple of nudie mags don't
mind it I uh Patty my sister popped my
brothers in a fight
oh yeah it took an earring out and
[ __ ] popped it wow yeah you could
have put a little Flex Seal on that and
hearing yeah but I think my uh
yeah and I think after that my mom was
like all right we gotta you know [ __ ]
West Side Story there are clearly
animals he had put her stuffed animal on
the roof of the house
he would go out climbing on the roof out
of one of the windows and he had a
stuffed out a stuffed pig and he she put
her her Pig got put on the roof he was a
real he was a real [ __ ] that day
I like his style my mom would come home
from work and he would be like on the
roof walking around smoking cigs and
she's like what are you doing she
couldn't go get him too
she's in Scrubs he just he just did
whatever he want until like he [ __ ]
you know the cops came or whatever
growing up my buddy's parents had you
know the full saw like they had like the
king size my aunt and uncle had a sick
one no but this was split because the
the mom didn't want the water bed so
they had like a single water bed and a
single regular mattress in the frame
because he liked the water bed and she
did it wow that's weird now that would
that
that's like having sex on the beach
what time's low tide
holy Jamie up the crabs start coming in
that's wild uh-huh man that I don't mind
um all right this one's uh this one's
from Kevin is a garbage to pack your
winter coat hold on start over is it
garbage to pack your kids winter coat
with beers when going into a football
game because they don't get patted down
by security
that's good I don't know if it's trashy
I don't know I've never been the
sneaking beers in anywhere I've never
been a fan really nah not a sneaker like
that you can't be at the movies yeah
sure but that's more of a selection
thing
yeah but there are so many more benefits
to sneaking booze in than sneaking candy
in I'm aware of that price wise yeah but
not even that but it's just waiting in
line those beer lines get [ __ ]
Bonkers sure they've gotten better with
it with the Stalls and the stands and
[ __ ] like that but if you sneak a sixer
and you save I don't know 80 bucks true
you save 80 bucks you don't have to wait
in line you drink your own brand not hey
we're out of Coors Light we have [ __ ]
Michelob I was always what if they
busted you let's just say hey dump those
out I got a three in jail let's throw
you out of the game in front of your kid
what do you want from him sorry
hey I don't know this little [ __ ]
he told me he'd give me a deal on a
ticket that's all I knew officer uh back
before they got back before they got
Keen to it uh we'd go to our uh the
games you'd wear the hoodie put beers
they would just search here or your bag
like if you had a bag and we everybody
put like three or four beers in your
hoodie and they wouldn't now they they
kind of they'll give you like the at
least the the grab or whatever but this
one no one yeah and I was like I was
like maybe we all put them in are we no
We snuck like 30 beers in between like
six or eight of us that's pretty good
time you know you put them in your butt
it's pretty good too they don't get them
yeah
okay you gotta use the pounder can I
need the big boys you gotta start off
with a pounder and get the other ones in
there my uh my my boy brought it stuck
into a music festival uh a tube of
sunscreen full of vodka and I never
forget him in the middle of a mosh
Prince squirting vodka yeah
three o'clock in the afternoon I mean
that's a big thing on cruises too the
shampoo bottle my stepdad did that they
were all going on a cruise him in
another you can't bring booze on the
cruise no because I want you to buy
their booze and their booze is expensive
really yeah I think everybody's allowed
like one bottle or something it's like
very it's like very regular do they look
through your bag yeah yeah they like
search your [ __ ] who does the cruise I
guess I don't know I'm not letting some
[ __ ] from [ __ ] Carnival Cruise
look through my bag I mean the TSA is
one that's a that's a government
organization I don't think it is though
the TSA isn't a government organizer
it's like one of those like third it's
real wonky that's just a [ __ ] guy
either way that's for sale I was working
at CVS yes two years ago that's for
safety though they're part of Homeland
Security there you go I don't know
that's Federal
some [ __ ] I'm pretty sure they're one
I remember Ari went on a back office
like Princess Cruises private tie it's
like one of those like weird
semi-privatized
someone's getting Caked Up they look
give that a Google they look through
your bag when you get on a cruise they
do yeah my my parents have [ __ ] you
dealt with that [ __ ] that
she got she got caught with a with an
empty leg
no but that's a big thing is everybody's
it's like the suitcase from Fear and
Loathing
you didn't pack one piece of clothes man
the first thing if you snipe how to
sneak in booze on a cruise pops up it's
like one of the main things they sell
and you can buy smugs jugs this guy's
hidden four bottle yeah you can buy
empty shampoo bottles like did they
don't there were certain bottles of
shampoo really you're bald I'm Persian
[Laughter]
um yeah that uh that I would do it but I
remember my dad weeks my stepdad weeks
out was like we got this we got the
shampoo he's gonna have the this he's
gonna have and like everybody went
strapped to the gills with [ __ ] with
booze because it's like it's very
expensive it's like twelve dollars a
drink or something imagine living in an
airport for four days that's what it's
like trying to get [ __ ] up too most
people on a cruise are going to get
[ __ ] up
that's crazy they look through your bag
I don't know if they still I mean that
was the big thing
um all right let's see here
the shh uh one sec um all right this one
is from Shelby first time long time
Shelby do you or anyone you know request
hot beer I once had a regular my
bartending days request we kept a 30
pack of Keystone by the cooler motor to
raise the temperature above room temp
that's crazy yeah that's a crazy person
that's a yeah that's nuts also the
Keystone what light yeah come on a
couple of Pebbles yeah they say one of
the mountain patterns that we're dealing
with that's track that's nuts I don't
even I need my beers gotta be screaming
warm Keystone screaming worm Keystone
Light you're asking for esophageal
cancer too that [ __ ] will burn dude they
go down so hard so they go down hard
when they're cold
what like Keystone I don't mind the
Keystone I've been getting back on the
light beers I'm off the ipas is that
right to retrieve them last night man
they really if you get off them for a
little while your tolerance dies down I
was googly-eyed in there I was making a
run on the waiter dude
yeah those things [ __ ] you up anymore
yeah it'll Goofy
oh really nice sister I'll clown you a
little bit smack you in the head pull
your ears
oh I heard a great term for beer
yesterday wobbly pops that's pretty good
wow a couple of two tree wobbly pops a
couple Weeble wobbles straighten me out
um all right this one's from Jeff when I
was growing up my dad didn't use an air
conditioner when he would get hot he
would lay in the front yard with a fan
and have us wipe him down with rubbing
alcohol to cool off
that seems crazy toxic that's too much
rubbing alcohol lay in the front yard
with a fan
why not do that in the house I guess the
fumes would get you yeah why make the
kids do it too why not you know what I
mean we're gonna put you know it's cheap
labor that's not long term that lasts
about 30 seconds
does feel good though
what the that's like putting like
mineral ice on it it's not really
lowering your temperature just it's like
makes you feel cool you know what I mean
I don't know I mean yeah that's garbage
yeah that's insane dead though right
same behavior Tucker T would just wait
until the last possible second to put it
in especially
going back to the 80s we didn't have an
air conditioner or we did and he didn't
I don't because I just remember one
night that's awesome you have central
air now you guys window units there's
your Center Rod you got to get that put
in because that's an older house no I
believe so yeah but how long have you
been in that house 20 30 years since the
80s 87 I believe
yeah they probably they've had it which
maybe it was in we no it wasn't because
we had one we had the biggest air
conditioner I've ever seen in my life in
the front window of our of the house
when we moved in for the first time yeah
for the first few years window unit on
the front yeah
the size of a pickup truck it was or
maybe it was in the back now it was in
the back it was in the back next to the
yeah and then that was the name before
they had it all all done but it was
sticking out heavy bike it was a huge
one it looked like a regular window unit
but it was [ __ ] like the size of a
refrigerator and that [ __ ] would [ __ ]
ice you down yeah nothing better than
that when it's hot out throwing on a
window unit and standing in front of
that thing God damn Pebbles off real
quick but in in my in my my the first
house that we lived in no AC no central
air and we would ride it out and I think
the one summer when it got real hot he
put it they put it in the living room
and we all slept downstairs in the
living room and they put blankets over
the the passageways into like the
hallway
it was fun you know like a Friday night
you're all in there snuggling you don't
know any better I know when you went
down the shore then when you walk
through that blanket you're like
you start wobbling yeah yeah it's like
walking into a [ __ ] good kitchen and
then one night I remember he was trying
to put it it was like three o'clock in
the morning my mom was bitching we were
all sleeping in their room and he was
trying to get the window unit in in in
the hole and he kept catching his
fingers damn it buddy [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know how good you got it good times uh
once you got that thing cooled down ooh
those good sleep tempers cool down too
everybody knocked out cold we uh we
didn't my dad never mind spending a buck
or two especially when we didn't have it
so he didn't mind just the air
conditioner was never a thing it was
always like turn it on whenever the
first hot day was that would get cooking
Denise at Denise's house she didn't have
a [ __ ] say that the inmates were
running the Asylum so she would be like
keep it on 78. we were like okay 70. and
he would just do whatever the [ __ ]
cooking a turkey we would just do
whatever the [ __ ] we wanted and then
when my stepdad came in he really tried
to rain like you know he's he's really
trying to Reign it all touch that AC
yeah he would they but he would go to
bed at like eight and he's a
construction worker he goes to bed at
like 7 15 he wakes up shivering he wakes
up I had that thing at like 67 dude just
[ __ ] like the Coors Light train he
wakes up with a cold God damn it yeah
I'm sweating it out in the living room
watching [ __ ] you know get out of
here dude not happening ah Patty runs
the uh thermostat uh gestapo regime they
still do it now crazy it's it's like
it's better to sleep cold no it's not
did you go home they all have they have
winter jackets on in the kitchen do a
bit about it of course be crazy
I remember the one time I walked on they
were both in [ __ ] ski jackets on the
couch watching Fox News I think you guys
look like you're on a ski lift right now
how the slopes buddy it's crazy yeah
it's kooky it's crazy they got people
get to a certain age and they uh I guess
they stop working they're on fixed
incomes
listen it cannot be that much more it
can't be I mean I think a couple hundred
bucks a month yeah it can be man it can
be a couple hundred whatever yeah if you
run it all the time come on it can be
200 bucks a month I think they're just
nuts what are you doing oh God I mean
from your perspective you spend every
dollar you've ever made until this point
myself included we're not we're not ones
to be like we've never saved a dollar
it's a different generation yeah yeah
we're spending it before we get it
they're like hey we gotta [ __ ] I
gotta live the next 35 years you you
gotta do three months left roll then
we'll [ __ ] burn the bridge
you got the Heat and the AC he going
just to let them know you can turn the
oven on let them duke it out
that's the saddest thing I've realized
about myself I've spent I've been
working since I was 12 and I've spent
every dollar I've ever made
don't most people do that no dude not
everybody does that you think most
people have savings saved up yes every
not every a lot of people Toby doesn't
yes he does not really for tax purposes
yeah I have my taxes saved up so do you
I don't know what you're getting at most
people have savings accounts like saving
savings yes oh really yeah you just have
the money that's yours you owe that
money to the government sure yeah that's
what I'm saying so I'm ready to go yeah
I'm saying you don't have like savings
no yeah that's what I'm saying we've
spent every dollar we've made until this
day you've been working for 30 years and
every single dollar you've gotten has
gone back into the economy which I
respect there you go yeah there's [ __ ]
man keeping the [ __ ] wheels turning
turn the AC up
and crack a window while you're at it
yeah I don't know yeah what are you
gonna do yeah I mean they yeah
we just we're very irresponsible with
money and we've always have been sure
our family generator our parents
generation was not no you know what I
mean no
but it is what it is they would scream
and yell
you ate everything I just bought it
turned that down wear that code again
don't lose that Terry yeah yeah uh shout
out to them all right let's see here uh
this is from Ian are you garbage if your
family if you all right sorry start over
this is from Ian are you garbage if your
family taxidermies the dog oh that's
that doesn't seem that seems it never
comes out right it's like plastic
surgery in the 80s like what are you
doing the technology is not there never
looks good man you know he's not alive I
get it from the perspective of like I
wanna you know it's uh you know they're
so close to their family member the
whole nine yards I get that but like the
execution of it and then it just doesn't
work I said listen I'm not a hunter okay
but I respect it uh I see Taxidermy as a
trophy as a look what I look look what I
did okay sure and some hunting obviously
um the little elephants and stuff like
that they're nice little things but
um there's a run around over the goddamn
place
[ __ ] mess up my Chevy Cavalier but
that's like a trophy when you know the
when you know the animal that seems a
little weird yeah I mean that at least
makes I could I guess I can kind of give
him a hug you say your goodbyes and and
you take care of it
sitting in a living room I got I yeah I
don't know doing like this thing you
know what I mean
playing fake catch uh yeah I don't know
I don't know am I doing the Harlem Shake
challenge my stepdad's dad was big into
Taxidermy well you like too too much but
deers we're like bears and yeah but
birds and quails and yeah you see you
start doing a couple of bears too which
would scare yeah dude my buddy Ernie his
dad had a fight that's a huge Bear yeah
huge huge hug they went up and he did
have a huge hug they went up through
Alaska or something like that and went
on like a hunting trip that's what those
dudes those Taxidermy dudes they seek
out to go get a certain thing and a lot
of you know it's a very it becomes like
a trophy obviously like a trophy trophy
hey we're going up to Canada that's this
is when the the [ __ ] quails are
flocking or whatever but it's like you
can't have like a deer or a lion's head
and then a pitbull head just [ __ ]
well I would argue the people that are
Taxidermy in the dog Pro maybe they are
Taxidermy people maybe you gotta you
gotta listen listen and I am still
feeding them every day and stuff
I'm the biggest animal lover love love
love love love
hate saying goodbye breaks my heart you
gotta let that go you can't be attacked
I mean the dog I've seen somebody
vacation and stuff yeah that's all no it
just looks like a bad pillow get a
painting or something yeah that's nice a
nice frame a nice picture family picture
so there you go there you go you can't
be having them like you know
yeah plus for like Stephen King purposes
that thing comes back pet cemetery
thanks
that movie Scared the [ __ ] Beijing
no way Jose I slept with the door locked
for a couple weeks after I saw that and
I saw it begrudgingly yeah if you do get
your pet Taxidermy put them in the crawl
space for sure yeah no kidding that's it
gang we gotta wrap it up gang we love
you and we'll see you next week peace